I'm also I've known a business from the
earliest purpose of my life is that you
rob people who look at the world famous
strength of character you're the warm
lost interest by poachers religion and
people thousands of molecules you
acknowledge debates with your history so
again I could not believe the news I was
here division into other planets
the people of Elinor and liquid mosques
in a moment of huge pain you stood up
and you stood together
and then we actually do trust you you
see something remarkable I've had
reasons myself to reflect a week and
some pain and today what I realize is
that of course we can change around the
shore the silence but I do not believe
the great changes who you are we if you
let it will reveal who you are they can
reveal depth you have
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you show the way we must respond you
showed
and violence simple acts like wearing a
headscarf rule to prep can reassure
those who have reason to be afraid
you shake an attack desire to divide
society against business only brought us
all closer to understand France there is
no community show the world the true
face of Islam as a religion of peace I
was very moved by the stories of the
great distances that your friends and
family traveled to support you in your
time of need even when your previous
connections they found people who faced
backgrounds can learn a great deal the
Muslim families affected by the attacks
running around the example provided by
diseases will prove to be an enduring
value to all nations what happened here
was fueled by Georgian that knows no
boundaries
the ones right united to fight extremism
there's a sort of sort of rebel cities
like Paris realized in recent days and
so too we must unite to fight the
violent random extremism
there's better base shootings in a
church in Charleston South Carolina and
a synagogue this book Sylvania about
tackling streets
[Music]
we
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]